で大きいです本でブース切って向こうがもっと持ったズレせますね配球を取る実験をし
てみようと思いますみなさんドアには2種類ある
すってますカオスドアと低いとはあると思います
私の住んでいる東京下にもをスタート匹たくさん塀の中にあるんですけどもどう見た
瞬間大須賀-買ってなかなかわかんないと思うんですよ
ますではもういつもこれ詰んでるわけじゃないしめちゃくちゃ支えられてるわけでも
ないこの部屋のドア僕ですらドローンドアがをすど旭区とはわからないかもしれないだ
パッと見た瞬間にその動画引くと技を曽田かっていうのは分からないんですよね気力
低下部屋の感覚とか間取りとかを初めて把握して違ってる部分で背に住んでいないよう
な僕とか僕以外の人はこの辺のとは
果たしてオス座が低く分かっているのはパッと見た瞬間わかんないと思うんですよ館学
的な問題でしかない
そうでしょなぜ寝るそうだな顔が
あーおきますこの部屋の中にある大須ドアには
-4そして引かなきゃいけないとだけはお寿司いる
この2倍を貼っていこうと思い
1倍で固定概念が覆ると思うんでしたこれだけが唯一のベースになると思うんで俺が
減った分で脳の情報を操作できると思うんですよこれを貼ればどんな道もオスドアだと
完成ですこれは張ればどんな道でも引くぞと歓声がでしょ
私ターゲットはどういう反応を示すのでしょうか
check 4
me
[音楽]
引っ込まれます
r
ん
ガー
tan
ポスターん
ええええええ
いつからか大数ですねえっ
いやをしたくなるがこれはいい
うん
重いです
me
ええええええ
[音楽]
ラインの館系
はぁっ
ということっ
ん
牧草お菓子からそう
th
牡7をしたろうと思うはかそんなんですっけ
4本
小園しろや
いや俺これやられたなぁえっ
[音楽]
やっぱりやりましたねん
ん
これん
これ一応
で保冷
[音楽]
もともと戻っていう
tuj 2
tan
こんなんだっけ7
20分
やっぱ安い you do
ni
ん
ああああああ
wh
me
uh
me あった